what is what is your relationship like
with your mother
oh god here we go fantastic my mom
actually is the one that is instilled a
lot of these beliefs in me she's the one
that told me that you know you got to be
careful these women are going to finesse
you etc it's actually my mom wow did she
get finessed no she actually married the
my parents are from sudan so she did the
finessing yeah she she married she
married my dad and that was her only
partner and they've been together the
entire time you have siblings yeah boys
sisters are they monogamy or no yeah
they're monogamous yeah
interesting your brothers are sisters
but my dad wasn't necessarily like rich
like he came to united states poor and
he worked his way up et cetera so but
right now he becomes in love with your
whole perspective and a change growing
up which which parent did you crave love
from more your mom or your dad oh [ __ ]
look at this is this like a intervention
should i should i lie down as well and
you know you get a notepad and you're
right whatever you see
no i mean like both my parents like
they're great like um
yeah
they both they they're both in my life
and you know i had a strong father
figure and
my mom was a great mom and she stood at
home and took care of us in my childhood
they gave you a lot of confidence yeah i
mean that's great i have really good
parents i tell them all the time i saw
them a couple days ago so i love that
that's why i this is why i'm like
i'm very grounded in understanding the
realities between men and women and
we're not the same so your mom taught
you a lot of these philosophies uh yeah
and then obviously from my faith etc
because you know in the islamic culture
you know men are men and women are women
and they kind of understand their roles
versus like here in the west it's a bit
more ambiguous are you practicing no i'm
a crappy muslim i will admit that i will
not lie on air but okay
haram but no i will i will uh i'm
definitely you know i'm gonna i'm slowly
acclimating back